now let's talk about some of the words
you're likely to hear if you're dealing
with insurance so the first one is a
premium or an insurance premium and
that's really just what you're paying in
order to get the insurance so if you pay
let's say 200 a month for health
insurance that 200 a month is your
premium now the other number or that
other word you'll hear a lot is
deductible now this is an amount of
money that you're going to have to pay
and then only when you get above that
amount then the insurance kicks in so
let's say your health insurance has a
five thousand dollar deductible and
let's say you have to go through some
type of unless it's the beginning of the
year usually it's based on a calendar
year and you have to get some type of
Health Care done and it costs two
thousand dollars well you're going to
pay that two thousand dollars out of
pocket you're going to pay that yourself
and because you haven't hit the
deductible yet let's say you have to go
in that same year do another thing that
costs uh three thousand dollars once
again you're going to pay that out of
pocket which is just another way of
saying you're going to pay that yourself
it's not going to come through insurance
but so far you have paid five thousand
dollars two thousand dollars for the
first thing three thousand dollars for
the second thing and now if you were to
go and let's say you have to get a
another five thousand dollar procedure
done in that same year now the insurance
will kick in because you used up your
deductible so if there's a five thousand
dollar deductible and you'll see it on
health insurance you'll see it on car
insurance you pay that first amount and
then the insurance kicks in above and
beyond that now you might say well why
would I ever have want a deductible well
usually the higher the deductible the
lower your premium you usually have to
pay less for insurance it has a high
deductible from an insurance company's
point of view they say okay the
deductible is kind of an incentive for
you to not necessarily use this service
you know get your car in a wreck all the
time or necessarily have to go to a
health uh care all the time and from
your point of view you might say hey you
know what I really I'm willing to take a
deductible because at the end of the day
insurance is really for if the bills
become really really really large so
just another example let's say your car
insurance has a five thousand dollar
well I'll use a different number let's
say your car insurance has a a one
thousand dollar deductible
and then you were to get into a some
type of a fender bender and the mechanic
says it's going to cost three thousand
dollars to repair this car well then you
would file a claim with your insurance
company that's saying hey something
happened I'm gonna need to get paid out
a little bit because I've been paying
this premium all this time and the
insurance company says okay we'll pay it
but you have a thousand dollar
deductible so you paid that thousand
dollars out of pocket and then we are
going to pay the remaining two thousand
dollars for that total of three thousand
dollars for the repair
now the last thing I'll talk about is
there's you there's oftentimes some type
of limit to uh the uh insurance policy
or you know sometimes they'll call it a
policy limit and that's this idea that
the insurance might cover you up to a
certain amount so let's say you have
liability insurance that's really just
Insurance in case someone sues you for
for doing something wrong usually that
has a limit to it so it might have a
hundred thousand dollar limit or five
hundred thousand dollars whatever it
means and that what that means is let's
say someone sues you and if the Court
decides that you have to pay them a
hundred thousand dollars let's say your
limit is a hundred thousand dollars then
the insurance company will pay the
hundred thousand dollars but let's say
the Court decides that you owe that
other person who just sued you for some
type of liability uh let's say you have
to owe them 125 000 well then the
insurance company will go up to the
hundred thousand and then you're going
to have to pay that other uh twenty five
thousand dollar out of pocket one last
word now that I really think about it uh
is the the notion of a copay and you're
going to see the a copay a lot when
you're thinking about health insurance
whether it's health insurance or dental
insurance and that's this idea that
let's say you go for your regular
checkups either your dental checkups or
your health care checkups you might see
co-pays at other places the actual cost
of that checkup might be three or four
hundred dollars and the insurance
company says you know what we will cover
some of this what we'll call
preventative care which is care that you
know checkups make sure you don't get
sicker and it makes sense for insurance
companies to do that because the sicker
you get the more expensive your health
your health bills could get but they say
there is some amount that you have to
pay alongside us so that's what the
copay is so for example what in my
health insurance I go I get a checkup I
have to pay a twenty dollar copay it
might cost a few hundred dollars of what
the insurance company's paying but I pay
twenty dollars alongside that so
hopefully you're a little bit uh more
knowledgeable about some of the words of
insurance I I obviously didn't I didn't
know all of these words until honestly I
had left college and I had to get
insurance myself so if you already know
these and especially if you haven't got
you know if you're younger you're very
much ahead of the Curve